this school known as the wolf pack
formed a group to get their masks back
yeah students at the university of
nevada reno they have them there tyrus
staged a walkout this week in protest of
their state removing its mask mandate
which is like demanding to keep your
seat belt on after you've stepped out of
your car
some 50 very well adjusted students
marched on campus to demand their school
keep masks in place even though nevada
ended their mandate on february 10th
these sound like the kind of students
who remind the teacher he promised a
quiz today
the governor had said they got rid of
the mandate because covet cases
plummeted yet an online petition to
reinstate the requirements has been
signed by over 2 000 people who've
either made coveted fear their religion
or just have really gross teeth
meanwhile a dad who tried to speak
without a mask at a suburban chicago
school board meeting got an earful from
a board member who was having none of it
we need to have you put on your mask sir
that's weird
i can't speak with my mask on i can't
articulate
i have a medical but you're not going to
honor medical and nobody
i have a mask
i could wear the mask on my head if you
want i mean it's just you can wear your
wearing your mask on your balls
here i thought i was the only one
finally coachella the popular outdoor
music festival not my third cousin
announced it's returning this year with
zero coveted restrictions no tests no
proof of vax no masks no fred durst
event organizers say if you're in a high
risk category like being poor or
unattractive
then maybe consider not going
instead go to one of jamie lisshout's
shows
where you never have to worry about
social distancing
oh now i feel bad cat you laughed at
that joke you're disgusting cat
apologize to jamie
no i'm not gonna apologize for being
disgusted what's wrong with kids these
days those kids okay well they're either
desperate to feel important or they're
stupid or both because they're wearing
the masks outside
and they're outside march and i'm not
okay there might be some masks that in
some situations are beneficial but
outside like you wear a condom to the
bar too buddy like you're what is wrong
with you wait what's wrong with that
well
somebody likes to be prepared
you never know and it takes a while
really not that much different you don't
need to wear a mask walking around
outside there's no reason for it other
than you want to like i i don't there's
no reason for it there's a big time when
you're putting on a condom that all
things could fall apart
so they can wear a mask if they want to
yes
they don't have to get a mandate back in
there and i just worry what happens when
something very difficult and unexpected
in their life actually visits them i
know that's what i worry about young
people like do you have do you know
anybody with this that happens it's
really hard you will be rejected you
won't get that seat in the college or
that job or that promotion or that
relationship and you're going to need to
have to cope with it maskless
that's the best point they're not saying
you can't wear your put it on yeah just
put it on that's it like somebody told
you tonight we don't have a dress code
and you took them seriously that's right
i told you not to mess with that woman
i don't think i even did anything
i think it got framed in a way that made
me i just like that i don't have to
insult you today no yes kellyanne's
taking taking up the sweetheart i like
to be funnier than a comedian you are
funny
um but honestly though like this story
is so
dumb that i misread the headline
you thought they you thought they didn't
want the mask i thought they were
leaving because of the meth that's how
dumb it is and then i even looked at the
video just to see if there were if
anybody's wearing like cloth masks and a
lot of them were not wearing the n95s
well let's read a book like let's like
let's really let's really do this you
know what i mean i don't know it's just
yeah it's no but it's sad
what's wrong tyrus you look like you're
crying because it's a little bit so i
had a friend named
in high school and i was mad that he had
a date and i didn't and i told him that
he had to wear it before because it's
you got to be ready you don't want to
not be able to put it on so i wore it
the whole time
he ended up telling her had it on and
she slapped him and she wouldn't be his
girlfriend anymore sorry
but that was funny but thank you
and i could just sum up this whole
photo's name
that's cool he'll be like oh i'm on tv
or if he's he could be you know who
knows he listened to that if he took
that advice god knows what happened to
him you know he blew up a condom
probably he killed 800 people but you
know shame on all of you for picking on
these kids
yes i told you before they're just slow
smart yes
learning changes in the past year
i looked into it and none of these kids
studied science and most of them were a
wrong side of history majors
[Laughter]
you're in the green stay there
all right
if your partner makes a racket in bed
would you sleep solo instead hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else